[Music]
this is major Roy McBride I'm attempting
to reach dr. Clifford McBride
this is dr. McBride son
dad I'd like to see Union
I recall how we used to watch black my
movies together musicals were your
favorite
I remember you tutoring me in math he
was tilden me a strong work ethic
you should know I've chosen a career
that you would approve of
[Music]
I've dedicated my life to the
exploration of space and I thank you for
that
[Music]
what is happening out there is a crisis
of unknown magnitude
[Music]
we believe your father may be involved
my father's dead what exactly are you
required for me
exploration is now is a noble venture
we have to hold out the possibility that
your father may be hiding from us
[Music]
we have a job to do are you ready I'm
ready
[Music]
take care major
careful good morning brass rods up there
on the international space antenna here
is a beautiful day
just perfect drying contact or get the
neighbors out there in the heaven
[Music]
control a vegetable in the arm over copy
that moving to the unit now
control I'm seeing the power steroids on
seatpost you getting that control we got
a lot of people up there over
[Music]
later I'll take trust five won't you
start with trust who don't wander off to
floor now best of Mississippi is
responding to you made a do you read
[Music]
ten approach
[Music]
this is a map of an underground lake
beneath the launch pad you'll be able to
access the ship from there you're
approaching you're gonna come for you
and I'm here
I need to get back now do what I can
good luck
[Music]
well how are you thanks for coming in
appreciate it general this is Lieutenant
General Rivas us face column special ops
sir agent adjutant general Vogel heavy
security ma'am they flew all the way in
from Virginia just last night just to
see you well thank you your profile is
certainly very impressive you've done
exceptionally well and all the
assessment tests basic combat space
training we have something of a highly
classified nature to show you major what
can you tell us about the Lima project
first manned expedition to the outer
solar system sir some 29 years ago and
that commander was was my father Sir the
ship disappeared approximately 16 years
into the mission I know David has ever
recovered deep space missions were
halted after that all right we have
something that might come as quite a
shock to you we believe your father is
still alive near Neptune and the
father's alive sir I believe so
boy the surge seems to be the result of
some kind of antimatter reaction now the
Lima project was powered by that
material and your father was in charge
of it we're talking about a potentially
unstoppable chain reaction here the
uncontrolled release of antimatter could
ultimately threaten the stability of our
entire solar system all life could be
destroyed major we would like you to
send a personal message on Mars by
secure laser to what we hope is the Lima
project what is happening out there is a
crisis of unknown magnitude now we're
counting on you to help us find him are
you with us yes I am sir
[Music]
some countries have been giving them
safe haven
they'll take hostages or go for our
Rovers it's like the Wild West out there
it's your first time in the war zone
three years over the Arctic Circle
and a heck of a lot army-navy games I
guess there's not much you ever see
right
well there's almost a full moon a large
stretch of the fosters real black so
pseudo
[Music]
the Big Blue Marble
[Music]
over seven confirm the settings to nine
arose
but we have what looks like unidentified
Rovers approaching our position possible
pirate activity
okay
we're not clear I repeat we are not
clear we have multiple enemy craft in
pursuit
major we have some highly classified
information looking in tell us about the
Lima project its objective was to search
for extraterrestrial life the ship
disappears sixteen years into the
mission and the commander was he was my
father soon as the film starts out we
learned that wife's father disappeared
13 years in the mission and there is a
possibility that he may actually still
be alive via father was experimenting
with the classified material that could
threaten our entire solar system it
becomes an epic journey through the
reachable universe
space comm requires the pre-launch
psychological evaluation I'm feeling
good
ready to do my job to the best of my
abilities Roy thinks that the answers to
life's riddles are in space and comes to
learn actually that the beauty of life
is the human connection you worry about
you beauty it's a very human story about
self and discover yourself what is
vulnerability what is strength
where does strength really come from
I'm ready
[Music]